what is happening there reject nation we
are here to watch umbrella academy
episode six of season three after that
cliffhanger revealing that mojo jojo was
back
yes that's his name right definitely
mm-hmm we know everything pogo's from
powerpuff girls you [ __ ] you're right
all right guys taking my monkey straight
leave a like
leave your thoughts down below on what
you think about this episode subscribe
and click that bell to get notified when
our reaction for the next umbrella
academy is up full length watch along as
we sync up with the time code rudder
patreon page
become a super sexy reject today but
checking all we got to offer and thanks
in the prepper boys for helping us edit
this down
you ready catch your breath you know you
can hear your nose breathing into the
microphone what this well that is that
better
[Music]
that's so we should do this filming
[Music]
that's what you guys came here for
all right let's do it
just because something is right in front
of you
does not mean
hey
it is within reach
oh damn there's always something in the
way looks great
sometimes it is your opponent
sometimes
it is
yourself
facts that's usually yourself
[Laughter]
thanks for calling me out pogo
[Music]
it was less wrinkly
that's cheating
[Music]
okay i guess tentacles don't count
matrix
oh you guys are ruining the dojo come on
guys
[Music]
hey it's your life
[Music]
ben that's enough let her go
jamie
close that
face enough no jamie will let us know
when she's had enough
oh no
stab him do it
yeah father you like that
smart work
ring that bell
very good
[Music]
very good child
suck it squid boy yeah
squid boy we never know what we're truly
capable of
until we're forced to confront our own
extinction and as their sensei it is my
job to make sure they never have to then
you overestimate yourself is that
foreshadowing
probably
[Laughter]
sending them to the other side now would
be suicide you've grown too attached my
old friend
lost your objectivity
and you've grown so detached you've lost
your humanity
what humanity
you forget yourself pogo okay that's the
hardest they're my children and they
will do whatever it is i ask of them
if you disapprove
perhaps you might find other employment
become a tattoo artist why wait
you can be gone in an hour damn
oh wow they're really attached to them
oh crap are you guys gonna make us care
about them now you son of a gun show
what is that
i think that's the
the the sedate hargraves pills
oh
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there's our umbrella there i see the
umbrella ah you guys are quick to point
out how we totally missed it in one
episode
it was like half the comments
as you and i have met before
back in 1963 when you were a diaper
wearing chimp time to go home to mommy
little guy
or what
that's crazy
not as crazy as that monkey talking
look man i don't even question it
anymore
or that
that's america's ass
damn
i did not realize the world was that
messed up right now hmm you think they'd
be on the news or something everyone has
their own vibration like uh sonic
fingerprint
what's mine sound like
wrong
ouch
the others are right we have to face
this cougar bliss yeah i know i know
okay well you have till tonight
otherwise i swear to god i'm in a room
with your ass to come back with me okay
yes yeah don't mess with me tiny that's
what aaron calls me
every day tiny
so i would greet him on the phone what's
up tiny
it makes me feel less that
makes me feel more than
you're stress eating like you do i'm not
all right what
what's really going on i had a
fight
with my sibling which one a couple
financially
there is one thing
i'm a thousand percent sure about your
math isn't great but
we can work with them
that's nice
ben needs a word great i'll be down in
intense not with you
[Laughter]
him
smooth oh
hey faye how's it going
how did you know we share a wall
your bed squeaks you nasty
all night
[Laughter]
nice luther
[Music]
who likes to move and move it you like
to
move it
[Music]
stan
[Music]
stanley oh my god does he turn into a
cockroach
oh you killed your son
that'd be really messed up
whoa
oh boy
that's some spooky [ __ ] it's a trippy
ass room
[Music]
is your bright idea to go into this
motorhome
[Music]
fascinating mm-hmm we just go in a
circle
i don't think so an ultimate dimension
things just got interesting beneath the
wind every living thing has an energy
wave a sound of its own uh i
i i can't concentrate
i want you to hear it that's a cool
effect
i can hear it
focus on it
let it flow through your body
that's trippy that he's training here
[Music]
that wasn't a rumor no there's something
else going on here you wouldn't be
risking your life like this
look whatever it is you can tell me you
don't have to be here
oh no
don't push her away well i don't have
anywhere else to go
[Music]
it's not wrong but i'm not gonna stand
here and watch you try to kill yourself
what is it victor trying to do trying to
take harlan's powers away yeah but
what's the deeper thing that allison's
picking up on that
he feels guilt because harlan killed
their parents
and she's oh yeah okay
god greg no i mean i i remember that i
didn't know that that's what he wasn't
talking about or that's what he was
concealing that i was like there's some
a bigger plan that i don't know about
[Laughter]
what's with your family's weird brother
ben fetish
he
you were the best of us
the jennifer incident why
it doesn't matter just know
that we were never the same without you
jennifer internet i'll take every second
of whatever version of you we've got i'm
not him you [ __ ] yes i know
i'm highly aware
[Laughter]
deny it
but he's in there
already had one
big dumb brother telling me what to do i
don't need another but the team might
grace
got another prediction
are you all right of course
why do you ask
open it
[Music]
[Laughter]
are you serious i'd rather have him with
us
than against us
aren't you gonna try it on you're about
marcus's size
no he's not
i'm honored
really i am i
[Music]
we'd all like to know
[Music]
you have some longer con here i'm just
waiting for your your character arc man
it's gonna happen it's gonna get there
eventually damn how long have you been
following pogo damn
it's been
that looks like my work but i never did
that tattoo not yet you haven't
i cut it off my hundred-year-old self ah
so desperate it is you would be too if
you knew the entire universe were at
stake so it's happened
pogo's so cool
i didn't respect much about the old man
but i respected that
was not his thing
alien language perhaps i don't know but
he referred to it as project oblivion
say what i need you to help me
understand certain things why you
locked me
in a mausoleum and slowed down my heart
rate
until i came to
in a pool of my own vomit damn
on the bicycle showed me but she might
be god she might be the devil
to say i don't know which is which you
are marvelously deranged
that's it
it's fascinating i don't know the
doctor's name but the difference between
what we saw on the flashback and how
he's playing him now is so it's it's so
small but it's
it's it's there it's prevalent yeah he's
great it's phenomenal come on
hello
it's asian here
hotel oblivion
hotel oblivion oh
that's right that's right
oh damn rudy's gonna kill me who's trudy
stan's mom wait
what
yikes julia
zan he's not our child oh my
that is so messed up that's awful
everything is fascinating ever since you
weaned me off those damned pills
i'd like to return the favor help you to
understand who you really are um would
you like that
maybe not naive but kinder
other than a probiotic yogurt that
doesn't make me fart and get over here
boy
oh i like nice hard grapes
don't go back to being mean please he
probably has some ultimate plan
definitely always has something up his
sleeve
what are you doing back there part one
of your healing
experimentation
[Music]
are you gonna board like kill him again
so you can experiment again oh frick
now that he's off his pills it's off his
rocker that's why i gave the children
those pills to keep them safe from him
well my druggy brother just got him
sober and project oblivion is starting
again and you are all in danger what is
he doing
i should probably get that ink
complete the loop
are you sure
oh i don't think destiny cares whether i
am or not
which is cruel ain't she
poggles freaking ripped dude i know
right
get started
it begins why is eating the tattoo now
complete the loop ah
you know how bees find pollen
the bees use the hairs on their body
to detect the interaction between the
fields they can hear the pollen
really what
you need to stop listening
with your ears
with your senses listen with your
feelings here's the force victor
you think ray's still alive no i'm
definitely not
she's just really really old i'm sure we
probably would have gotten along just
fine hmm
more than fine she would have loved you
the way that i loved you
the way i still love you
oh i love you too baby oh
and you know i'm always gonna love you
please stop why because you're not real
don't say that the ray i know died nine
years ago at the age of 82. i looked it
up well
you're right i can't get back to you or
claire
you're both gone forever and it's like
you were never real
no matter when or where you are we're
both always gonna be with you so you
have got to do what it takes to survive
this
promise me the memories are real allison
[Music]
i like how they kept the sound of the
chain moving on the swing the whole time
he was talking oh did they i didn't know
yeah yeah it was kind of distracting but
i liked it
i got sucked in bro i was like yeah
memories they're
with you oh what the what is happening
you guys are doing a great job
whoa
looks like
shanghi versus the mandarin
[Laughter]
whoa that's cool
is it
working
i think so
[Music]
[Music]
damn how they always just land on their
feet they didn't they totally like but
they landed first like they went like
that they didn't stranger things did it
here
like you'd like fall in your ass first
hey
[Applause]
harlan
we did it
okay he's okay okay
hey hey he's okay
now you can tell i wasn't he killed your
family now kill him
so
stan is adopted okay yeah that's fine
that's fine i was adopted i i turned out
pretty well no i'm not adopted i
borrowed him from my mate trudy for a
week
lila did you kidnap a kid she went on
holiday and he needed some fun and i
wanted to see what kind of dad she'd
make you know stress just kicking tires
are you insane i hate this this hits
close to home man i don't like it
deserves better than this sonny's in on
it oh jesus wow
ah
you got a perverted way of thinking he's
already having a laugh we just need to
forget him i'll deal with this myself
well we should probably stay in one
place what if he wanders by
wow
i'm mad
well he must be from florida bro i swear
it's okay i know why you don't like me
no you don't so you freaking know i
don't like the hold you have on my
brother that's because of what i did
to all of you
why is he
confessing this
because he thinks that
why all
he
right
that victor todd actually told you oh
yikes
about the mothers oh
that victor told him that he wouldn't
say something i don't think so
it was an accident i didn't mean to hurt
them you're the reason claire's dead my
power spilled over i got in mine and the
reason the whole world is ending i
couldn't stop myself victor knew
oh oh oh don't don't don't
don't do something crazy because what
you say when you spill a glass of milk
not obliterate somebody's child
oh no
this is not good
what are you gonna do don't do nothing
stupid don't rumor him please don't do
nothing
[Music]
stan
i'm nervous
oh [ __ ] hey
oh what is this hotel fascinating
you need to get out of here not without
stan
oh my god
oh my god
are you kidding me
oh no
it's a reaper
[Laughter]
[Music]
you had to get back to that door homie
you go back to that that portal
what is that
oh
stanley just in the room
he's trying to live behind them
[Laughter]
you got it where the hell were you
oh the kid doesn't have time to get a
slushie in a slim jim
[Laughter]
oh it was obsidian on that side
yeah oh stanley god damn no
that was pretty sweet but like damn
man that sucks losing your fingers like
that
yeah man you gotta go back for those put
those on ice or something i'm sewn back
on
dang
oh that's messed up yeah
she killed him
she freaking killed him did she like
actually murder him oh my god oh geez
he's in the zoo what the freak
yikes no bro
this can't be real
is this
no
[Music]
tensions rising
oh my goodness
oh my god this is crazy i'll get this
out of the way this is bananas
ben did not bother me he didn't bother
me
he didn't bother me at all
he wasn't as angsty
all right
this episode either i was like okay all
right they're getting a little better i
know some people who just
like this whole season um
still don't mess with them oh allison
allison really she didn't bother me as
much this season you know what as much
as we've been planning about this season
the one thing i do think i appreciate is
the fact that she's been rumoring a lot
more than previous seasons yeah she's
actually using her power which i'm like
okay cool yeah
if she had a twitter
[Laughter]
she like audio rumor stuff i heard a
rumor that
you know hugh jackman's in the next mcu
movie can she make [ __ ] like that happen
she just controls the narrative of
hollywood
from her phone he can stupid powerful
all right let's talk about it yeah i
like that episode i liked it a lot i
think it's been the best episode so far
it's pretty great one
i like this season overall i do
um
like it just
like when i don't like it when i'm not
liking it i'm really not liking it and
then when i'm liking it i'm really
liking it so whatever the lasting
feeling is is the feeling i associate
with the season basically so if i'm like
if i don't really like an episode i'm
like man this season if i really like
i'm like that's a good episode it's
always been it's always been even so far
it's true we're about to hit an odd i
mean there are people who love every
episode but it's interesting living in
this
superhero age because everyone seems to
be on the same page about
multi-dimensions and
smashing [ __ ] together and multiverses
timeline everything is doing even
freaking superman lois is doing it right
now so um
yeah it's just kind of crazy to see how
everything's been doing that and
i do like how they are mixing things up
you know there's some stuff i could feel
could use a little bit more you know
meat
to really
motivate certain choices
uh
like like like luther putting on the
sparrow outfit like i know you like the
sparrows and you're really and you're
really in love with sloane
and maybe that's
enough to motivate it i still feel like
i could
use something that really demonstrates
like you know the sparrows are something
better to join than then the umbrella
there's no defining like turning point
for him to be like okay i've had enough
of my family i need to switch sides yeah
let me fix this for you so
freckling you can hear the crackling
yeah there you go there's better
yeah there's no defining thing oh that
does a lot better yeah you can hear now
yeah it's really directional um
yeah so that's kind of the thing that
was a little missing for me but
i like what it does as a plot maneuver
uh for creating some tension with our
characters 100 no i think it's um
yeah i think it's really interesting the
way the season's been playing out you
know especially as we're getting into
the crux of what's actually going on
like we had the introduction of the the
googleplex or whatever the frick it's
called google google kegel please google
blitz google blitz yeah something like
that
yeah man i think uh
i i like
how each of our characters are are
growing and exploring these different
aspects of themselves that have kind of
brought them to this point that feels
it's starting to feel a little bit more
natural like i know the beginning i felt
was a little rocky but now we're
starting to get into places that make
sense for these characters
and yeah i think the foundation of my
enjoyment of these the show has been
from
the characters that we have been
following like granted the plot only
elevated that but i think
even if the show is not firing on all
cylinders the characters themselves will
make it work for me uh like the season
hasn't been my favorite season that
we've seen so far but i've never not
enjoyed it
overall like the characters are enough
to make me still want to continue to
watch and watching where everybody is
and the motivations they have for why
they're doing what they're doing
really uh elevates how we're going about
things like i really enjoying the the
klaus and hargrave stuff i like seeing
five unite with pogo again
uh allison is trying to become a real
threat because of the pain she's she's
going through and we're seeing a whole
new layer to her which we didn't really
get to see her as like a forefront
character in previous seasons which
granted no matter how you feel whether
she's like a little too angsty or you're
into this new direction
uh it's starting to
affect the plot in in meaningful ways in
big ways like i'm pretty sure she killed
harlan it was just like whoa
you know like she's not i've never known
her to be like a straight-up murderer
before after we've seen thus far
yeah well
i mean maybe she didn't kill him but
just remember him to be unconscious or
something his eyes were open though yeah
we're going to be like
i heard you were unconscious with your
eyes
i heard you played dead i tried to give
uh benefits of the doubt but no i could
see her killing i mean i get it her
whole reality she's
since the beginning of the show is there
people who really hate her this season
maybe she just gets worse
um
but i i could see how her mind broke
because
you know out of anyone in this if i'm
not mistaken like from the first season
you know she was the
she was like an actress who was like a
working like as a famous person she made
it the best out of all of them yeah and
then when she goes back in time she
finds love and
racism and finds racism that didn't
exist before
uprooted and found it
uh so she's always so she found love and
yeah because i remember her things
weren't good with her
she was like separated from her husband
or something in the first episode first
season yeah divorced but she had her kid
so she lost like her child and the love
of her life and the spouse and then
i could see her mind like shattering
just completely breaking to the point of
like i i i guess
out of all things i've been critical of
of not loving a lot of certain choices
i've weirdly
adjusted to allison faster than i feel
like a lot of people have i'm like no i
gotta get it you know yeah i think it
clicked for me
in this episode we're like grant i did
have my issues with how
the character was moving and her her
actions but i i
knew that it would stem from a point of
pain but seeing rey and her on the the
swings really hit it home for me and i
think that made me realize why i haven't
really been liking ben so much this
season is because all of the sparrow
academy we don't know much about them
outside of what we're seeing in the
present so they haven't anchored them in
a point of empathy for us to
like them or dislike them because we
don't grant it we dislike them but like
we don't have like
they don't feel fleshed out they don't
feel like people they just feel like
some sort of opposition without death to
them well that's why i like the
hargraves reveal here that
i think it's really cool how they
managed to take that meaningful thing of
klaus and hargraves bonding with each
other
to klaus helping out hargraves and the
way you see it in the lens of the
umbrella academy at least from klaus's
perspective especially
is that
they are abusing hard graves yeah and
they are taking advantage of him and and
suppressing him because the sparrow
academy is all evil and then come to
find out that
they were
actually doing probably the best choice
inspired by
uh pogo
to suppress him
because he's
truly
evil
and he's got a real kind of mess like i
don't really understand the details of
this oblivion plan
but it's called oblivion right
and
even in the way hargraves is acting and
going back to his old self like i think
that's a cool
it's it's rather insidious in the way
everything was kind of creeping up where
you know klaus reunites with har graves
in this episode and it seems like it's
going to be really tender but like oh my
god is back to being all messed up again
and then seeing the flashbacks prior to
you know when when pogo was still around
that hargraves really is he's he's
actually worse in this timeline yeah
he's he's worse than he was before
whereas like the whole time they've had
us fooled
that hargraves is actually a better
human being
but he's not he's actually a worse
person yeah and
i think that's a really neat reveal be
like oh crap he's actually evil and
klaus actually messed us all up
you know and i i think that is a really
cool twist uh to to throw on us and back
to the luther thing really quick the
only the thing that saves it is the fact
that i like his chemistry with sloane i
really like tom uh hopper's performance
a lot i think it's just a really strong
performance yeah and um yeah i mean
vanya and victor
uh nope mess that up sorry guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
victor
i'm a justin i apologize we're just
sorry
okay victor and and harlan
right there you go yes coming up with a
bunch of names here victor harlan
and um
[Music]
i
i guess i'm just remembering it wrong i
i could have sworn that victor told
harlan that
to not say anything and that he wasn't
gonna say something that victor said he
wasn't gonna say something but
i don't know i guess i just remembered
it wrong i think yeah i think he just
said that he's going to keep harlan safe
i don't think he ever said that he's
going to not say anything to the other
uh umbrella cat at me or i think when
they left off victor said i'm uh i'll
i'll tell them but i don't think victor
told that and told harlan that he never
actually said anything yeah which you
know added to
the the complexity of of these
characters dynamics and the fact that
victor already harbors in so much guilt
for all the things that he's done over
the course of the season so he just
blames himself
for
yeah their mom's getting killed which is
why he wouldn't say anything both
because he blames himself and because he
cares for harlem because it's his the
love of his life son yeah
well
[ __ ] happens man
get over it uh and then this whole thing
with
diego and
lila i didn't realize it wasn't called
oblivion from the start it was what was
obsidian and then the other side is
oblivion hotel oblivion
yeah i don't know what's going on hope
they explain it because that was
confusing as [ __ ] it looks like
obviously an alternate dimension but
like i don't know what's going on over
there or what that reaper kind of
character is yeah i wonder if that's the
next step for the show because we've
gone to we've gone back in time we've
gotten alternate timelines i wonder if
it's multiverse now alternate dimensions
maybe that's season four it's clearly an
alternate dimension yeah you know or if
it's the other side of the hotel
the exclusive side the vip
um
well i mean the thing with lila and the
whole thing about stanley not being his
actual kid
that was messed up that's really messed
up man yeah i really like them as a
father and son too yeah man as someone
who's experienced something similar to
that that really uh they really hit me
in uh you raised a kid no i got i got i
thought i was gonna have a kid to find
out i wasn't having a kid
that's for another time though sounds
like a different story it felt similar
you know what i'm talking about i know
it's what you're talking about she told
him that it was his kid and then it
wasn't his kid yeah
i need to clarify cuz people are
probably gonna can i clarify a little
bit sure yeah yeah
someone basically told aaron
that they were gonna have a kid but it
was a lie just to test aaron out and
aaron it was frank aaron had been fooled
for quite a significant amount of time
into thinking this was really gonna
happen
but this person then confessed that they
only did it
to test my character to test to see yeah
which is what lyla did
diego's character yeah yeah um
i didn't want it to sound like it was
something else
it could sound like something else okay
that's fair yeah but yeah that is that
is what happened
the the abridged version of what
happened yes yeah um
so i i get you on that i thought it was
funny
what happened to you not them yeah
i don't understand the point of her
doing that yeah i don't know like she's
been around for decades right like what
i don't know man but
you know at least it brought them back
together and our little homeboy is dead
or he's gone for right now you know
cougar blitz cougar blitz he got blitzed
but he died with like the perfect
landing of a slushy which i was
very impressed by yeah
i i don't i'm waiting to see a lot of
this pans out but i like the direction
it's going now especially now where more
of the cards have been revealed have now
that there's a mystery and like we
actually starting to find out like
what's actually going down or there's
there's there's a level of intrigue
beyond the characters at this point yeah
there's also like a lot of twists and
turns and like pogo coming back and
knowing more that the fact that because
pogo had always been loyal to hargraves
yeah but in this timeline for pogo
to
leave you know because hargraves is so
far gone
from being anything remotely human
um
yeah i think my question at this point
is why would hargraves raise continue to
raise a superhero team like he did in
the original timeline just for him to
have some sinister ulterior motive well
that's what we got to find out oh yeah
we haven't seen the episodes yet so i'm
just like can a man ponder
i could have met a lot of questions
can a man wonder not in this day and age
thoughts get you cancelled now man
you better be careful with what you
ponder
but you ask questions about
damn questions
but no he did what he said something at
the beginning of the episode like
prepare for extinction or something like
that
true for fear for the end was like
clearly foreign
so he would the oblivion obviously but
what does that mean and why you know we
know that he's an alien they haven't
really touched or talked about that at
all in this season but i figure that's
going to come
something into play with what we're
going to see
going forward i mean that's what the
episode is that's what the oblivion plan
entails and that must be what the
when when
pogo was showing like
you know um some type of alien symbols
and language in front of one i'm gonna
sit him with five
and then even at one point you know he
does say like what humanity
when pogo is arguing with him
so there's some hints of that there's
more to come to unveil about that but
i'm liking it i am i do like it and uh
you know there's often a very black and
white thinking when it comes to how
people perceive
opinions on youtube
or in general
but no overall i am liking it and i'm
not i don't
i don't dislike it you know there have
been some things that have been pretty
hit or miss for me
more so than the other seasons but
overall i'm still still enjoying it and
still want to finish it
yeah it's uh it's great it's only
turning up the heat not as fast as the
other seasons did but you know now that
we're here now that we're literally in
the middle in the thick of it yeah i'm
like yeah man i can't wait to get to see
where we go
can't wait to see how this ride turns
out
the third one yeah third one
can't wait to see how uh
how uh the gang
flips it around
that wasn't getting a man pondered
you may have some time to think of a
better one
all right guys
well thank you for being here thanks
aaron for stopping on by now you got a
busy schedule yourself
guys what'd you think leave your
thoughts down below hey we will uh
catch you all soon but after this
patreon
ricardo martinez
ricardo
do you know what your name means
do you
um
it means king richard was will smith no
you you [ __ ] [ __ ] sorry ricardo
idiot
i'll keep your name out of my mouth this
is why our dynamic doesn't change
you don't do research on things that you
don't know i'm gonna talk about
you know that's the best way to get
spontaneous reactions that's how you
catch people in the know
how
ricardo means king ruler and hard brave
oh my guess was half right no you
weren't even close
well you are a king and ruler of all the
latinos at our patreon page
because
i think you're like one of two people
that we shout out regularly king carter
have a latino name
and it's hard and brave to be part of
our patreon page ricardo not many people
decide to do it
million subs at only a couple thousand
two thousand yes
so you have taken the brave leap here
you i hope you keep those pesos on auto
roll oh
john told me to say that joke
right not me now say the one about the
tacos no i don't want to say the burrito
joke i don't want
i returned the sombrero to amazon say
something about the border and the
border is something i agree with ricardo
do you still want to be
pledged
end of show
i'm just kidding ricardo you are the
king ricardo i hope you're enjoying some
tacos today go get yourself a black bean
quesarito from taco bell
i hope that for your next birthday you
got an awesome mariachi band
playing there for you
loud and proud at one in the morning in
a neighborhood full of white people
where they call the cops and complain
about gang bangers in their
neighborhood low rider and uh hey if you
need some family to cross the border
go on right ahead i support this let's
go to a dodgers game
yeah that works
stereotypes accomplish we've spent a
long time
saying terrible things
see how far we can push you before you
decide to unpledge
thank you for being here bud hopefully
you picked up on the fact that john's
just being sarcastic and i'm being 100
sincere
[Music]